next we'll return to unprecedented
prosperity through our pro-american
policies
we'll pass new tax cuts to boost
take-home pay we're
going to be cutting taxes very
substantially we get it back
through growth we had tremendous growth
until we get hit with the china virus
we'll continue our historic regulatory
reduction campaign we've
as you know in three and a half years
we've cut more regulations than any
other administration
no matter how long no matter what period
of time you're talking about
we'll enact fair trade deals and we're
working on
seven major fair trade deals right now
and when i say fair fair to our country
because our country was ripped off by
every nation friend foe
didn't matter every nation was ripping
us off
at a level that it's just unbelievable
to be honest
we're going to be expanding opportunity
zones
and we will
keep that going it's been a tremendous a
tremendous program i want to thank
senator scott
south carolina for coming up with
that whole concept because he came up
and i liked it right away and it was
it's really turned out to be a
tremendous thing especially for
african-americans hispanic americans
will continue to unleash american energy
we're number one in the world
and we're totally energy independent
right now and in 2021 will create
10 million jobs at least in the first 10
months